let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 and see what is on people's minds
today let's start with our caller from
the a 4 to 3 area code today who's
calling from 4 to 3
Aman
that is you my friend okay well I
appreciate you having me on of course in
columns from the great city of
Chattanooga Tennessee brilliant
yes border city of Tennessee in Georgia
anyway please I've been on my mind you
know we've got the 2020 election coming
up here pretty soon
yep and me I consider myself a centrist
libertarian basically uh you know pretty
fine with anybody that really does
anything as long as they don't infringe
my right kind of thing and really the
last guy I want to win the election was
in 2012 when Ron Paul would you like
about him other than that well I mean he
was pretty simplified you know he was
basically for really anything as long as
he didn't you know you didn't fringe on
your constitutional rights and he was an
isolationist you know you wanted to get
out of the wars which by the way we're
still in we've been for the last 20
years and we spent trillions of dollars
on it's not worked and both parties have
not worked and for example the right
wing you've had the rise of what I call
the uber Patriots right
the uber yes I people call them the
alt-right I call them the uber Patriots
but uh yeah you've had the rise of them
and then of course a lot of people on on
the left you've kind of had this divide
and that's what's caused a lot of the
people on the left and not win as much I
think I agree that the left has not been
do not not been doing a lot of winning
but I just saw a pretty good study which
shows that the left is actually less
divided than the right currently and I
find the data motivate a believable so I
don't know that that I I agree with your
assessment that the left has been doing
a lot of losing I don't think it's
because the left is divided though
right and this past election if Bernie
had been in I would have voted for him
because he's the only one actually
somewhat light okay and Hillary you know
like I didn't like her I didn't like
Trump or either I actually made a long
Facebook post about how I actually if
you think about it they're very well
connected with each other and honestly I
thought you know it was a ploy to keep
Bernie out of it you think that but you
know let's not you what was a ploy to
keep Bernie out but Trump running and
Hillary being the nominee in total was a
plot to prevent Bernie from being the
president you're saying yes I know it
sounds crazy but let me explain you said
it not me
because right anyways basically I
believe that because if you look at
historically they've been great friends
for years
and all of a sudden you know he decides
to run as a Republican and if you look
at his political stances historically
he's a big flip flopper he doesn't stay
with one party he's never been
consistent on anything he doesn't steal
things yeah I get it yeah and another
thing to another phrase I've heard you
couldn't believe in this town if his
tongue was notarized
but anyways and but so let me ask you
let's get to down to the to the
nitty-gritty of it what overarching
group or entity would coordinate both
the Republican and the Democratic
nominees in order to prevent Bernie from
being president like who set that up
well I mean the Democratic National
Committee's to where he was when they
heavily worked for Clinton yes and also
too she had the suit and she had the
super PACs which I'm heavily against I
believe we should get rid I got you but
don't get off-track though so okay we
know that the DNC favored Hillary but
where does the conspiracy to have Trump
and Hillary run against each other to
keep Bernie out
come from well I believe in a weird way
that Trump might advise way onto the
Republican nominee to I'm sorry if I'm
not making bad you know it's not making
sense I think I think you're realizing
it doesn't really make sense here's I
think here's what happened hillary was
the nominee because the DNC favored
Hillary Trump was the nominee because
Republicans lost their minds and he was
able to use the combination of you know
clever nicknames and the idea of being
an outsider to an electorate that was
well primed to fall for it partially
because of their hatred for Obama I
think that they were two different
things that took place I don't I don't
agree with your assessment that there
was a unified conspiracy for it to be
Trump versus Hillary so that Bernie
wouldn't be president that's my view
actually well I appreciate that you
actually helped me clarify a little bit
I've just been kind of confused over
this alright good well I'm glad glad to
allay your confusion and I really
appreciate the call but I've got to move
on because I've got a bunch of people
who want to get on here today